buenos días soy el presidente del
consejo europeo sales michelle ha
asegurado que es un día histórico porque
hoy se espera que los líderes europeos
puedan dar luz verde a que moldavia y
ucrania puedan convertirse en países
candidatos a la unión europea a priori
no hay ningún país europeo que se oponga
a esta posición pero se trata aún así de
un primer paso ucrania y moldavia tienen
que seguir con la reforma sobre todo en
el estado de derecho y también en la
lucha contra la corrupción de hecho la
comisión europea a finales de este año
tendrá que publicar un informe en que
explique si están confirmándose estás en
reformas o no tras ello pueden pasar
años hasta que estos países puedan
convertirse realmente en miembros de la
unión europea pueden ser candidatos
durante muchos años pero aún así se
trata de un importante monto mensaje un
símbolo importante para estos países que
tan sólo hace cuatro meses que pidieron
entrar dentro de la unión europea y es
especialmente importante para ucrania un
país en guerra y este mensaje importa
mucho en política los mensajes y en la
guerra son especialmente importantes
extraer también los países balcanes
occidentales han expresado su
descontento y frutos también llevan años
esperando en esta lista para pertenecer
a la europea porque ha sido tan lento el
proceso en estos casos
si así se debe a una serie de
circunstancias hay países que llevan
esperando como comentabas durante muchos
años y ellos también están pidiendo hoy
aquí en bruselas que también se les
tenga en cuenta por ejemplo macedonia el
norte lleva 17 años siendo país
candidato también albania lleva casi 10
años de hecho hoy se esperaba que
podrían empezar las negociaciones con
estos dos países pero lo cierto es que
bulgaria bloquea porque insiste en que
se reconozca que macedonia del norte y
bulgaria mantienen estrechos lazos
lingüísticos y políticos por una
situación política lleva años bloqueando
se en otras circunstancias como países
como bosnia que lleva eternamente siendo
un país potencialmente candidato pero
necesita hacer reformas después de la
guerra que aún no se han acabado de
producir serbia con importantes lazos
con rusia y también aún debe solucionar
su situación con kosovo todo esto está
complicando mucho el proceso de atención
aún así la unión europea quiere dejar
muy claro un mensaje de que apoyará a
esta región y más aún en plena guerra en
ucrania porque hay que tener en cuenta
que rusia ejerce una potente
muy potente influencia en esta región es
algo que la unión europea quiere evitar